[Music]
would you take your next vacation on
this slimy beach
[Music]
well what if most of our beaches were
starting to look like this because our
oceans were quickly being taken over by
this green sludge
this isn't nuclear waste people are
swimming in its algae and if it took
over all our oceans it would change a
lot more about our lives than just how
we vacation why could it be deadly to
swim in algae what would it do to our
bodies and how would it help us save the
planet this is what if and here's what
would happen if algae took over our
oceans the idea of algae taking over the
entirety of our oceans may seem a little
far-fetched but it's already taking over
smaller bodies of water around the world
when algae grows densely and out of
control it's called an algal bloom and
in 2019
there was an algal bloom that was so
large it could be seen from space
not only did it look really gross but it
was also incredibly dangerous since it
produced toxic effects for both animals
and humans but despite all the danger
involved if algae took over our oceans
it could also do wonders for our planet
as it would quickly become our biggest
weapon against climate change
and that leaves us with a dilemma should
we fight the algie's takeover or embrace
it
[Music]
before we can answer that question we're
going to have to become a little more
acquainted with the green stuff
say hello to algae you may only know it
as the weird green stuff that grows on
rocks but there's a lot more to it
algae is an informal term for a large
diverse group of aquatic organisms that
have the ability to conduct
photosynthesis they can occur in a
variety of forms and sizes from single
microscopic cells to seaweeds and if
they took over our oceans they could
provide a much-needed helping hand in
our fight against climate change no
matter what trees or plants try to tell
you algae is the real master of
photosynthesis it provides more than
half of the oxygen in our atmosphere via
phytoplankton and seaweed and it
consumes more carbon dioxide than trees
while trees take generations to mature
enough to really make a dent in carbon
concentration algae grows quickly and
spreads widely giving it the potential
to be even better at absorbing and
consuming carbon than our woody friends
and algae isn't just good for cleaning
the air some kinds of algae can also
provide food for marine life food for
humans and be used as nutritional
supplements but perhaps the most
intriguing possibility of a world with
algae filled oceans is how algae could
be used to replace some of the most
harmful products on our planet like oil
based plastics some of the biggest oil
companies are now researching whether
algae can be used as a sustainable fuel
source as some researchers think it
might be possible to produce 19 thousand
liters of biofuel from a single acre of
algae in one year
so if we had entire oceans of this stuff
we could do a lot of good for the planet
by reducing our use of fossil fuels and
by removing some contaminants from the
air but keep in mind that our oceans are
gigantic and filling them with green
sludge is bound to have some negative
effects on the species that rely on them
large masses of algae can block out the
sunlight for smaller organisms living
near or under it causing aquatic plants
to die
and once the aquatic plants are gone the
fish shellfish and other marine animals
that eat them would follow closely
behind harmful algal blooms such as
brown or red tides and blue-green algae
can contaminate public water supplies or
can accumulate in the bodies of smaller
aquatic animals that are consumed by
larger ones resulting in illness or
death in whales sea lions otters and
manatees among others people who eat
shellfish containing dangerous algae can
suffer diarrhea seizures and even death
so if we want to harness all the
positive impacts of algae there might be
a better option than allowing it to take
over our oceans maybe we could farm
algae in land based facilities instead
we obviously wouldn't be able to produce
an oceans worth of algae but we could
still provide material for other uses
without depriving fish and other
vegetation of sunlight with the help of
algae maybe we could even double the
amount of oxygen in our atmosphere but
you know that that's a story for another
what if
[Music]